oh let's get more on this now flip
Ingram is with me for a senior military
intelligence and security officer
um so Philip this is interesting change
she is at the very top of the military
command involved in this war in Ukraine
who are now the key players what does
this change mean it is well we have to
remember this is day 323 of Vladimir
Putin's 10-day special Ministry
operation and he's at the top of the
tree he is the overall an overall
command but it seems that he's
increasingly distrusting as military
commanders because he's reaching down
with what we call the long screwdriver
right into the Tactical battles and
ordering some things around and making
tactical decisions his right-hand man
politically is his Minister of Defense
um General schrugo 67 years old he's
been Minister of Defense since 2012. he
was part of the planning for the
annexation of Crimea in 2014 and part of
the planning for this special military
operation
um let's talk about this reshuffle here
the military commanders in that well as
you touched in there your general
grasimov who is the chief of the general
staff of the Russian Armed Forces has
this been given the additional title of
the commander of the joint group of
troops so he's overall responsible for
everything that's going on inside
Ukraine it's not clear whether he's
giving up his other post or this is an
additional post 67 years old he's a
Putin Ally he's been in major
decision-making roles militarily since
the Chechen Wars of 1999 so obviously
involved in planning this special
military operation and Crimea in 2014.
um he's pushed aside General suvarican
the youngest of all of the generals that
are in there he's only 56. he's an Air
Force General nickname General
Armageddon because of what he did inside
Syria
um but he's now one of three deputies
that exist
to grasemoff but he was appointed in
October um since then he oversaw the
withdrawal of Russian troops from
Harrison the disastrous attack on from a
Russian perspective a fantastic attack
from Ukrainian active on New Year's Day
McIver where a large number of Russian
troops were were killed and he's been
the master of the suicide drone attacks
onto critical National infrastructure in
Ukraine as he said sirovakin has only
been in the position for three months
he's now been moved aside if you like is
this common should should we read much
into it this reshuffle
um there's a lot of angst going on
inside the command control structure
Putin has lost control and he's being
influenced by this final character that
there is in here
um who is
the head of the Wagner group this
private military company that comes in
he's got political Ambitions or we're
starting to get indications he has to
potentially be Putin's successor but
he's got a direct line into into Putin
and he has openly criticized shogu and
garasimov for what they've been doing
and he when people openly criticize what
they've been doing militarily they tend
to fall out of a window from the ninth
floor or fall down the stairs he hasn't
which shows that he's got you know that
that protection from Putin um
interestingly he has praised suvariken
so this dynamic in this relationship
whenever from a military perspective
he's doing all the stuff in back mode at
the moment or his troops are he should
be under grasshamoff he's not um and
where he's fitting in and the waste
during the pot is I think causing people
real angst okay Philip thank you running
us through some of the key players there
uh in the uh Russian regime
involved in this war in Ukraine thank
you Philippine we'll speak to you later
on thank you